question for astronauts
where
your poop will go
i'll translate
where does the poop grant a poop hi i'm
mike massimino today i'm going to answer
your questions on twitter this
is space support
[Music]
at happy grampy asks
nasa what do astronauts do as they're
blasting into infinity and beyond at
37.3 bazillion miles per hour under 27.2
g's that's only part one of the question
there's more to follow but with those
numbers i'm not sure what you would do
glassing into infinity and beyond don't
sign up for that we go to definite
places i went to hubble space telescope
you can go to the international space
station have you picked
37.3 bazillion miles per hour seems a
little bit too fast i think that's over
any speed limit now i feel like a
slowpoke we actually in orbit we go 17
500 miles an hour and it says under 27.2
g's which i don't think that would be
pleasant either we take up to three g's
are they telling jokes throwing up
praying holding on to their seats for
dear life until they're in orbit pretty
much all the above i would say yeah you
hit just about everything joke telling
is more for the launch pad before
you go to space so you're like sitting
there lying on your back for a few hours
typically it was a responsibility of the
pilot to supply jokes that was their job
do i remember any jokes that the pilot
said on the no maybe i just wasn't
paying attention like i should have to
the jokes because you know we're about
to launch into space i also play
tic-tac-toe with my buddy and rock paper
scissors that kind of thing throwing up
really doesn't happen until after you
get to space lots more of a zero gravity
issue so you're not throwing up during
the launch praying absolutely throughout
the launch i found myself doing that and
holding on to your seats you're strapped
in so you don't have to really hold on
to anything it's all those things but
it's also an amazing experience at peter
peach asks why do astronauts need belts
in space and i'm looking at a photograph
of my friend megan macarthur and they're
wearing belts
so why do you need belts in space kind
of a good question but i think it's just
to keep your pants up you're not going
to have gravity pulling your pants down
but if your pants aren't fitting really
well they'll kind of float around you
but having a belt i use the belt in fact
look at this i'm using a belt now i wore
this belt in space this is actual a
flown in space belt so i brought my own
belt to space to keep my pants on
correctly and i think it's more of a
comfort thing and also maybe some
excuses to get a belt flown in space
because i was able to bring it home and
wear it this next one is from at miguel
tavares how do astronauts get leverage
when attempting to unscrew tough bolts
you can use your body and gravity on
earth so seems a little difficult while
floating this is a really good question
and something we do think about as
miguel says when we're on on earth you
can brace yourself against something and
you're on the ground you're not floating
away in space when you push on something
you're going to go the other direction
so you're really not going to get
anywhere if you do that what we do is we
make sure that we are stable so when i
was working on the hubble space
telescope my feet would be in a in a
foot restraint so my feet are nice and
solid and then i could
react that force through my feet if i
didn't have my feet and foot restraints
i would try to push the wrench and my
feet would go flying this way another
interesting thing maybe a little more
advanced to think about is when you're
undoing a bolt or you're going through a
hard stop on a bolt and you get to the
end it's going to give you a kick well
if you're not steady that you know the
tool will go flying so we would always
think about reacting it with our arm
we're out there in our spacesuits we'd
be in our foot restraints and i'd always
have my arm in position to absorb that
kick that we would get at the end so
we're a lot steadier on earth when we
work with tools and work on things in
space it's a little more challenging but
i prefer it's a lot more fun
at dima hajj question for astronauts
only for astronauts
where
your poop will go on the space shuttles
we did have a commode it was not a flush
toilet it had a seat on it it was fairly
complicated you had to turn it on and
create a vacuum and make sure everything
was where it's supposed to and and then
every couple days the poop would be kind
of compressed it was a very ingenious
way they did it had these different
screens and so poop would be in there
and then one screen would go and compact
it and then more poop and then another
but we just collected that poop over the
course of a couple weeks everybody's
poop went into the same thing we brought
all that poop back with us
for no reason other than we didn't know
what else to do with it i think i don't
think there was any science behind it
but that poop came back to earth and it
was serviced on the ground never to be
seen again as far as i know the space
station is a little bit different the
toilet is a can with a seat on top of it
and a plastic bag is a liner so you poop
into that
can you close up the the bag and then
you
get it to the bottom of the can
and you put a new liner in for the next
person clean up and you're done once
that cam fills up you take the seat off
you cap it and you put it in a cargo
ship that is now a dumpster there are
certain cargo ships that come up and
then they don't return to earth with
anything they're used as dumpsters so
all your waste garbage things you don't
need go in there it gets sealed off
after a while it reenters and everything
burns up during reentry that is a much
better way to go
the shuttle toilet was very expensive
and complicated this thing is a can and
it works really well so that's where a
poop goes
or
or poo poo as it says at vwb58
why do astronauts have mirrors on their
gloves this is a really good question i
think we have mirrors on our gloves when
we launch into space in case there's
an instrument or a panel or something
you need to see behind you it's really
hard when you're launching into space or
when you're landing to move your head
around you have a helmet you can kind of
turn your head a little bit but you
can't really see behind you so well so
having a mirror right on your wrist
makes it easier to see behind you if you
look closely at a spacewalking suit the
emu the eva mobility unit and you look
at the way these con these controls are
labeled they're reversed so when you
hold up the mirror to it it all is in
the in the right orientation another
thing about the mirrors i thought was
interesting is they're not actually
glass
because you don't want to have glass
around the space suit it could shatter
it can cut things no good so they're
actually highly polished metal they
polish the heck out of them to make them
shiny so that's why we wear wrist
mirrors they're very very helpful
particularly during a spacewalk
will taft asks to astro illini astro
illini is my good friend mike hopkins by
the way real good guy mike if you're
listening how are you hope you're doing
well miss you all right does nasa put
any time in the schedule to give
first-time spacewalkers a minute to take
it in yes and no the first few minutes
of your spacewalk are considered to be
translation adaptation of your very
first time spacewalking it's the first
time you're out there you're in the big
suit just like you were in your training
but we typically train underwater
so when you're under water and you're
moving around you move differently than
when you're in air or also when you're
in space we call it spacewalking but
really what you're doing is using your
hands to move around so as you move
around with your hands you want to go
very very lightly and very slowly if you
put too much oomph into it that's not a
good thing you'll go flying now in the
water you kind of need that extra oomph
because the water viscosity slows you
down it makes you more stable requires a
little more force to move around you get
to space there's nothing there's not
even any air to slow you down there's no
resistance at all so the same type of
motion that you would use in the pool
will send you flying somewhere you don't
want to go
in space so the first 15 minutes or so
are usually dedicated to you just to get
used to moving around it's not really
look around take it in have fun it's get
used to that environment so you can do
your job
at free the stones
asks space travel question
it's about fuel once you get your
spaceship pointing in the right
direction and get going do you need to
keep your engines going in other words
do you only need to save fuel to either
change speed direction or to slow down
if you're in an orbit around or around
earth let's let's take that as the
example here there still is a little bit
of drag now if you're familiar with the
drag equation
it's velocity squared if you have a
large amount of velocity like 17 0500
miles an hour you square that that's a
really big number so even just a little
bit of resistance can give you enough
drag that eventually the orbit will
decay from atmospheric drag even though
it's just little traces of it there's
still a little bit you'll get lower and
lower and eventually re-enter the planet
which is what happens sometimes some
spacecraft will slow down enough and
they'll come back into earth usually
they'll burn up in the atmosphere and
re-entry or if anything makes it through
it'll land in the ocean or some place
where people aren't around so it
typically isn't a problem but that will
happen the only way to prevent that is
to increase your altitude and go back up
and give it a boost so for example when
i visited the hubble space telescope we
gave it a boost and it raised its orbit
and it kept it up we'll keep it up in
space for a longer period of time if
you're on your way to another another
place on you know going to going to the
moon or to mars or something like that
it's going to be a little bit different
you would just need to coordinate your
speed use your fuel to maybe slow down
to enter the orbit correctly but you're
not necessarily worried about the
orbital decay that you would experience
on earth when you're not in orbit if
you're traveling somewhere else then you
do have to uh manage the fuel usage with
not only with your straight trajectory
but when you encounter whatever the
target is you're going to you need some
fuel to slow down and enter into the
orbit correctly at christo
cs
asks do spacesuits fit well are they
even remotely comfortable
yeah as best as you can get them you
know you're not going to uh you're not
going to a tailor but they do their job
i think they're adequate are they even
remotely comfortable yeah they're all
right you know you wouldn't want to wear
one around town necessarily but for what
they what their function is and what
they need to do to protect you yeah i
would say they are comfortable at kyo
pajinkuk
ask nasa as an astronaut how many
languages do you have to learn to be
able to communicate with the crews from
other countries it's not just english
right that's true it's not just english
anymore for going to the international
space station you're going to operate
and work there as a as a nasa astronaut
or as an astronaut from the european
space agency or canada or japanese space
agency or the russian space agency you
need to be able to speak two two
languages because it's russian the
russian segment u.s segment the u.s
segment we speak english as the primary
language on the russian segment it's
russian on the u.s side he needed to be
able to get along pretty well in russian
and the same for the russians in english
so yes two languages required on the
space station at christine one
two
asks my wife just turned to me and asked
baby do you think space smells
i have no idea how to answer this
question so if you're inside the cabin
you're in a pressurized environment and
space will smell like things smell here
on earth if you're smelling food or each
other use your imagination it'll smell
the same the question might be more of
what the space smell like this requires
a longer answer but we're not doing a
longer answer we're gonna do a short
answer it has what it there i got to go
with the long answer when i was a new
astronaut sergey krikalev a russian
cosmonaut had just come he had been on
mirror a few times on space station here
he just came back from a shuttle flight
and he said there was a very distinct
odor you come inside the airlock you
close the door to space and you open the
door to the spacecraft inside when you
enter that airlock is what sergey told
me it was the same smell on mir as it
was on the space shuttle it doesn't last
for long because that air starts to mix
with the air in the cabin and the smell
goes away but on my first mission i
wanted to check this out so sure enough
after the first spacewalk i was not
outside i was inside for this first
spacewalk helping the guys outside as
soon as the spacewalk was over i opened
up the hatch i went in there started
smelling i've got a good nose for
smelling
and it was this very metallic smell
almost like a burnt metal smell it's
very distinct and i'd like to think
that's what space smells like at almira
a mcl
asks mike massimino is in big bang
theory ah
yes i was on the big bang theory ah hey
fruit loops want to hit your fan switch
that was a very cool experience i got a
chance to be on the show the way that
happened was nasa called me up said hey
mike do you know about the big bang
theory and i said yeah it's this big
explosion and the universe is expanding
he goes no no no no this show and i was
like yeah i think at that time i had it
i wasn't that familiar with the show i
kind of heard of it but he said they
wanted to speak to an astronaut about
sending a person to space and i was
having to be in los angeles maybe a
couple weeks later and i went by the
warner brothers studio to the writers
room which was extraordinary bill prady
and chuck laurie the creators of the
show and their writing team was there
and i told them stories kind of like i'm
telling you now and they
wanted to work some of these ideas into
their scripts so i helped them a little
bit with that i went to see a taping and
about six months after all this
they got a note from bill crady one of
the creators and he said hey mike we'd
like you to do a cameo what do you think
and i was like okay so i went in and i
did a cameo and that led to six more and
a lot of good friendships out of that
with the cast and the crew and it was a
great experience the point of all that
is sometimes you just need to say yes
thanks for all your questions this has
been space support